Mao Zedong led the Communist Party to
victory in the Chinese Civil War and
declared the formation of the People's
Republic of China in 1949 which he ruled
until his death in 1976 Jung Chang and
John Holliday attempt to demythologize
the chairman in Mao the unknown story
they spoke about it recently at Harvard
University in Cambridge Massachusetts
for about an hour ok good afternoon I'm
Michael Ignatieff I'm the director of
the Carr Center for Human Rights policy
at the Kennedy School of Government at
Harvard University this event is
sponsored by the Carr Center for Human
Rights policy at the Kennedy School to
my immediate left Jung Chang and to my
far left Jon Halliday authors of this
extremely important book Mao the unknown
story this is the product of at least 10
years of work archival work in many
countries including Russia frequent
visits to China an attempt to interview
every single living person who talked to
Mao in a senior leadership position that
is to say one of the features of the
research base of this book is that they
interviewed every living American
president who saw who met Mao yes so
it's a book of very very substantial
research base and it is self-evident
layton a biography of Mao is a history
of the 20th century China a biography of
Mao is self-evidently therefore an
extremely important book in it in and of
itself what I want to do is talk to the
authors about the book for about a half
an hour 40 minutes and then there are
two microphones
here and here and if you want to ask a
question and a question is one of those
short interrogative stunt statements
that ends in a question mark
it is sharply distinguished from a
statement which is a longer discursive
product that goes nowhere so we're
looking for those little short
interrogative statements and they will
be happy to answer and then the event
will end in about 45 minutes and then
there will be a book signing afterwards
and the books are on sale above you so
let let's start here this is a book that
is both an extraordinary act of archival
research but it's also a very personal
book because Jung Chang is as most of
you know the author of Wild Swans her
unforgettable account of what it was
like for her family to go through the
Cultural Revolution the last of the
convulsive acts of Mao's hold on power
so I'm just wanting young whether you
could explain to us the connection
between the Wild Swans project and the
Mao project right um after Wild Swans
was published in 1991 here in the US and
in 1992 in Britain and I was thinking
about writing another book and Mao
seemed to be the obvious subject because
he dominated by early life and I saw him
turning the lives of the court of the
world's population upside down and yet I
felt the world knew astonishing the
little about him and I myself didn't
know that much and I wanted to find out
a bit more so I mean to write this book
was also a journey of understanding of
this man who played such an important
role in my own life and in the lives of
the Chinese there is a line in many of
the reviews of this book that says that
this biography is your revenge
for what happened because joking aside
even as a pleasantry the cultural
revolution inflicted untold harm and
horror to realize including your own
family so is there some sense even if
you didn't intend it as such in which it
it became a very personal act of revenge
or am i completely on the wrong track
well I mean the thing is you know my
father died in the Cultural Revolution
prematurely and my grandmother died and
and I wrote about all that in Wild Swans
I think the past was for me was supposed
to rest with the writing of Wild Swans
so when I approached this project and it
was more out of a curiosity I I just
think revenge by the way I think there
was nothing wrong for Mouse victims to
want to get even with him and he was
responsible for well over 70 million
death of the Chinese in peacetime but
that mean personally I just think
revenge is a negative is a negative
emotion it's sort of it consumes if I
wanted to have revenge II would consume
me more than probably the the subject
was dead and and so I didn't I I can say
honestly I a what that was not my
motivation let's just observe in passing
the huge significance of the the number
that just slipped out in that last
answer that mouths a tongue the book
claims was responsible for 70 million
deaths which would then make him by some
considerable distance the worst tyrant
in a century full of unspeakable tyranny
I mean is that I'm going to get to John
in a minute but just young one more time
was that in some sense the central
surprise of
the sheer scale of what this man had
accomplished um but what they [ __ ] when
you I knew now had caused a lot of death
I'm out of this 17 million 38 million
died in the Great Famine in China
between 1958 and 1961 I knew about this
family I wrote about it and I thought
the famine was the result of economic
mismanagement Mao was no good at econ at
economics but during our research I mean
it suddenly dawned on me this wasn't
true I mean ma was no good at economics
but um he knew this number of people
would die he had actually built their
death in to step into his policy because
he was exporting the food they were
dependent on for survival
to Russia to buy nuclear technology and
equipment and arms industries for his
dream of becoming a military superpower
so he could dominate the world in his
lifetime I mean he intended for this
number of people to die and that took me
totally by surprise I was I just didn't
imagine that at all and also more
shockingly and after tens of millions of
people had died Mao didn't want to stop
he said for all his projects to take off
half of China may well have to die and
that again was very very shocking to me
and you know one year Wild Swans I wrote
that you know tens of millions of deaths
I had made Mao see that his policy
didn't work so he was forced to change
his policy but then during our research
for my biography I realized that he
didn't want to stop and and his number
two President Leo had to ambush him and
force him to stop and Mao was
furious so furious that he wanted to
revenge and the Cultural Revolution was
the primarily mouse revenge against his
number two and the party for stopping
his policies that caused all these kinds
of millions of death I want I want to
return to the question of the
motivations here that is why this is a
form of tyranny that seems so specially
indifferent to human life which was what
was where you ended but I wanted to just
ask John to talk about the degree to
which this experiment the communist
experiment in China was derivative
essentially on Russian models one of the
things that I found exceptionally
interesting about the book just
historically was the incredible
influence of the Comintern in the
International communist movement and
Russian Soviet agents on the shaping and
direction of a policy can you talk a
little bit about the Russian side of
this story and then get to the the
$64,000 question the degree to which
that ideology and those people were
responsible for some of the carnage that
Young has outlined here alright um okay
well I mean I this I mean there's
probably at least a couple of big issues
in there I mean one it may I turn I'm
into the issue of how Stalin brought Mao
to power is do we want to get into that
now or not okay okay
well I I would say for me and the stuff
I worked on in the Russian patch because
Young did all the Chinese stuff and so I
would say the biggest surprise for me
was the that Stalin had not only
supported Marvin very early on but had
actually spotted Mao from as early as
the late 1920s and had then a the myth
of course that Mao himself put around
was that he somehow rose to power
without Russian
and rather against the wishes of the
Russians who according to him were
supporting some other people in the
Chinese commonly der ship that turns out
to be completely untrue and in fact we
discovered or we documented that in 1932
when Mao's colleagues threw him out of
power because they couldn't stand him
the Russians insisted that they bring
him back in and work with him and then
again in 1934 just before the long march
Mao's colleagues cabled Moscow and asked
the Russians if they would take him off
their hands and take him to Moscow and
the Russians refused and said you have
to work with him and so on so the the I
mean one of the questions that often
comes up is you know how did Mao make it
when he wasn't popular and you know how
did his colleagues continue to work with
him well certainly in the story of the
rise to power the backing of Stalin is
absolutely critical I mean if we just
jump fast forward because there to to
perhaps what was in also in Michaels
question is the the influence of the
Russians well I mean in in the Russian
archives I mean one file that opened up
just before I got there thank goodness I
mean was a file on Russia and the
Chinese Communist Party up to 1943 and
it had about a quarter of a million
pages in it including lots of stuff in
Chinese original Chinese documents and
you can see that it is a day it's a day
to day relationship I mean some days
there are several cables and eventually
that moves into a day to day
relationship between Stalin and Mao in
fact Mao was the only communist leader
in the world that Stalin communicated
with on this this kind of regular basis
even before mark came to power in 1949
and then when when the UM Mao gets to
power I would sort of in a nutshell I
mean somebody else use this phrase not
me
he can't power at a time of your high
Stalinism and nineteen if Stalin is
alive for the first four three and a
half years of mouse
rain and in a way one could almost say
the very worst of Stalinism is what gets
landed on China but but Mao wanted that
I mean it's not just that Stalin said
you have to run the Chinese state very
like the Soviet state it was it was what
Mao and his and his colleagues went for
and I mean in recent years in fact the
documents have come to light showing
that in the years 1949 particularly
1950-51 the Chinese Communists are going
to Moscow with the plans for
establishing the Chinese state down to
the very last detail and and now you can
even read some of these things they've
been published with Stalin's annotations
in the margin you know about about
everything I mean about how to deal with
missionary schools how to deal with
small shopkeepers how to deal with
industry how to deal with agriculture
how do everything install and we're
right you know very good or you know
great or you know on the line in the
margin so so the influence is in sir
it's very very strong in it but is there
I mean there is an image I have of a
peasant boy who comes out of an unjust
society a poor society pre-revolutionary
China and burns with a sense of
injustice towards the societies born in
and that that indigenous source sense of
injustice pairs with 20th century
communist ideology the to spark and you
get the Chinese Revolution it seems to
me your book offers quite a substantial
corrective to that to that view right
yes well I'm afraid that was my view
before we have know before we found I
mean up to the time of research and I
used to think that was the case but then
after we studied every word Mao wrote in
his youth and everything I mean on
record he say
and we just couldn't find anything that
showed his care for the peasants I mean
there was just nothing I'm on the
contrary he said for example in his
village it was easy for peasants to get
rich and he showed not he showed no
sympathy he didn't think the peasants
lives were hard and that was the thing I
mean we had to go by the evidence I mean
there are there were other communist
leaders who did come from very poor
peasant background for example the
Defense Minister pankaja who came from
very poor background had very hard
childhood and was very close stayed
closed with the peasant roots and then
he behaved behaved very differently from
Mao
I mean sure in the famine he would be
moved he was moved enough to try to
challenge Mao to try even to contemplate
a coup - to contemplate you know getting
help from yeast in Europe to stop Bao
and Mao just didn't have that sort of
care I mean he said later in his life
you know you're always going on about
the peasants lives or heart I never
thought so and he said you know having
only tree leaves to eat which his
colleagues told him that there was the
state of the peasants during the famine
and Mao said so beard and the peasants
were starving
I mean Mao said in writing I've been
educate the peasants to eat less I mean
he said numerous these things which were
documented in our book and and that was
the that was the person but is it but it
is it possible that instead of a kind of
sentimental sense of injustice about old
China there was something else a burning
hatred of Chinese backwardness and a
burning longing to make China a world
power and a determination to break any
obstacle that stood in his ways that is
that the core of what he believes as a
political actor I mean that was what I
thought before but then again as we
discovered that wasn't the case I mean
Mao became a communist not because he
was pursuing some sort of ideal or this
ideology but because he was at the right
place at the right time in 1920 the
Russians were founding a Chinese
Communist Party by the way even the idea
of the Chinese Communist Party came from
Moscow and they suggested it to the
founder of the of this chance Communist
Party and so it was founded in 1920 and
and that founding father of the CCP
prophet a professor Chen Mao visited in
1920 in Shanghai and so professor Chen
gave Mao a job to start a bookshop
setting radical literature particular
literature for the newly founded
Communist Party Mao loved books here you
know his later yes he had these huge
beds half of it would be piled a foot
high with books so he could wake up roll
over
pick up a book and start reading of
course then he wouldn't allow hundreds
of millions of Chinese to read so but
that was later then but in 1920 Mao was
given this job at all from a bookshop he
was a delighted
he was also poor and welcomed the income
and that gave him a substantial income
so that's how our God kind of
incorporated into the communist
organization so it's it's opportunism
not not ideology not conviction not
belief yeah yeah yeah I mean I I'm quite
skeptical about the ideology we could
come back to that but it certainly isn't
conviction one of the most interesting
to me one of the most interesting we're
really
statements Mao made was in 1923 when he
was he been in the Communist Party for
less than three years and he said
communism hasn't got a hope of working
in China the only way it's ever going to
work is if the Russian army brings it in
from the north ah so he so he didn't he
didn't he'll work and actually you can
we you can smell in his writings or he
never puts it in these words but you can
smell that he he himself reckons the
only way this thing will only work by
force and Mao himself never put a single
one of his his ideas all the ideas of
communism to the test in any forum
throughout the whole of China he never
went out on the Sun you know the street
corner and made a speech about building
hospitals or schools or anything like
that he never held an election and
moreover as you probably know in the
Chinese Civil War between 1945 and 49
unlike Cuba Vietnam and Russia there
wasn't a single uprising in any city or
town in the whole of China that's
perhaps going beyond the issue of Mars
conviction but I mean in just one word
about ideology which I think is a very
it is it's very important to understand
Mao's thinking or his relationship
somehow to what was by then his marks
ISM not Marxism as a system of analysis
as Marx himself you know in his better
moments was using it but Marxism as the
established ideology of the Soviet Union
or communist power in 1929 when other
people in the Chinese Communist Party
people had joined it in the hope that
the some of the ideas of communism might
be realized and particularly the idea of
equality in a society that where there
was a great deal of inequality but Mao
didn't want equality inside the
Communist Party so he hit this on the
head he invented a crime called ultra
Galit arianism and denounced anybody who
advocated equality and
on that moment on equality or advocating
equality was taboo in the Chinese
Communist Party and one result is you
get very very hierarchical system with
you know different levels of food
clothes etc for party officials and
ordinary right right through this new
Chinese good so it's in my opinion it's
it's it's impossible to to argue that
you know whatever one may think of
Marxism or communism it's impossible to
argue that mal advocated the core ideals
original ideals of that system but then
then we it seems to me have a puzzle
which is at the center of the book if it
isn't a burning sense of injustice if it
isn't deep in the enduring scars of his
own oppression as a you know young
person if it isn't fervent belief in
communism there isn't a I get impression
sometimes that you've you've done a
biography of a black hole and then the
question is what do you think really
drives in particular mouths relation to
revolutionary violence because whatever
s this book is it's a biography of an
extremely violent man using violence
continuously to achieve political means
but there's a kind of black hole in the
center and you can't figure out what's
propelling this but there was the most
powerful motivation and I think the
motivation for probably vast majority of
a powerful men throughout history and
that is power and Mao was extremely
power hungry and I was single-minded and
perhaps more single-minded than most but
power is is just the most powerful
motivation the personal power for
himself and there was another aspect
which is Mao loved violence and he
realized that in 1927 when he was a 34
before that he had been reasonably
moderate he was a low
warm believer he was in the party but
not very committed but then in 1927 he
went to the countryside of Hunan
province his home province there he saw
peasant violence and atrocities stirred
up by the Soviet model and Mao wrote
himself he said this tour of 32 days
changed his life and he felt a kind of
ecstasy he had never felt before I mean
he just loved that violence of peasants
against landowners what kind of violence
was it that he observed in Hunan with
mostly thug violence I mean were a lot
of poor people against the rich of
course but not just the poor people
against rich but just people you know
Miami kind of having a tree treated
atrocious leather enemies or the
relatively rich em you know the Chinese
rich in the country in the Chinese
villages in those days were just meant
to you have two more chickens than your
neighbors probably but never that I mean
still Mao wasn't interested in the land
issue wasn't interested in
redistribution of wealth and he was his
you just report about this tour he wrote
almost exclusively on the violence issue
I mean that violence and I think
triggered off something in himself he
had found himself he'd loved it I mean
then from then on he became a learning
list star dienes not through the pursuit
of ideology but by finding his own
character well one of the things that is
said in criticism of the book is that
this vision of this tyrant is somehow
one-dimensional that is its unrelieved
in its emphasis on his immorality and
and and attachment to violence and is
not balanced by anything l
that would make the character
sufficiently nuanced to really
understand him I'm just wondering how
you react to the critique that it's a
one-dimensional portrait either of you
well um I mean if we just take the
period let's just take the period when
Mao was actually in power I mean 1949 to
1976 it in during those years I didn't
somebody calculated there was something
like 74 or 75 political campaigns in
those years many of which overlapped and
in many of these and it starts in 1949
with a very large number of executions
and I think as you mentioned Mao made
sure that you know executions were
carried out in public I mean he pushed
violence into the public arena in a way
that no other dictator did other
dictators did other things some many
worse things but in terms of the
constant arm use of violence to
intimidate people the entire population
and also to try and get as large a
number of people in the population to
inflict violence on other people is
something unique about Mao's reign I
mean Hitler and Stalin inflicted
horrific violence but but first of all
that violence was carried out mainly by
a leads
I mean KGB Gestapo and so on and be
mainly in secret not in the public
mainly it not in the public domain
Mao very deliberately pushed violence
into the public in order to terrorize
the population and from then on it is
relentless I mean it's not if I may put
it this way it's not that we are
relentless about now Mao himself was
relentless a visa V the Chinese people
and he himself said we are you know at
one point he said you know the whole
country hates us the peasants haters the
quedas haters you know we're at war anny
men we're
or the Communists here the Communist
leader was basically at war with his own
country and it did it never let up in an
either level one is the level of fear of
population being made to live in
constant fear and secondly it didn't let
up economically because right
the very first five-year plan when Mars
Prime Minister Joe Enlai took the
five-year plan to Stalin Stalin's first
comment was your level of spending on
military matters is unbelievably high
it's higher than Russia we had in the
middle of the war against the Germans
and I believe Russian multi spending was
fifty six percent of whatever I can
remember is the budget oh gee anyway at
the time and the it Mao's figure was in
the sixty percent from the very word go
and did and the level of Taxation and
the level of military spending were
constants throughout Missouri so he was
relentless in how he treated his own
population and I think that I mean to my
own surprise and we mark we did find
that mal was completely immoral but that
doesn't mean our portrait of Mao is
one-dimensional because morality is only
one dimension but there are many other
dimensions of Mao I mean do for example
he was as I just said he loved the books
he wrote very good poetry I mean he was
a strategist I'm you know he for example
when the Japanese invaded China and
everybody wanted to fight Japan but if
the Chinese Communist Party had fought
Japan it would have been wiped out or
severely weakened so they would never
have a chance to get to power Mao was
the only person within the Communist
leadership who insisted on not fight in
Japan and but to exploit the opportunity
to
to get the Japanese to defeat his
domestic enemy Chiang kai-shek to you
neighbor the Communists to come to power
and Mao was extremely successful and
without mouth at the change comes party
would never have come to power so he had
far sides you know he was a schema and
and there were many other many other
dimensions of him and he for example he
was also he was a opera opera lover
Chinese opera lover and had a huge
collection of opera cassettes and and
was something of a connoisseur but of
course the problem was he wouldn't allow
hundreds of millions of Chinese to watch
operas you know when I was growing up
there were only eight so-called you know
Revolutionary shows produced by his wife
so there are all these many sides of Mao
which I think our book brought to life
is amazing I mean I myself understood
now for the first time before I didn't
understand why he did all these purges
why the Cultural Revolution and all that
I mean I I think I did it does help
people understand MA let me ask one
final question which is about my legacy
in the relation of Mao's legacy to the
current regime in China and that's by
way of announcing also that those who
have questions should go now to the mics
because I'll be calling on you and I'll
try and take as many in order as I can
before we stop at five your book ends
with today MOUs portrait and his corpse
still dominate Tiananmen Square in the
heart of the Chinese capital the current
communist regime declares itself to be
Mao's air and fur fiercely perpetuates
the myth of Mao but is there some other
sense in which part of the legitimacy of
the current regime is to publicly ivali
with Mao but actively in the way they
run the economy break with Mao utterly
so that in fact the relationship of Mao
to the present is a
perhaps more ambiguous than your
epilogue suggests you have any thoughts
about how we should understand Mao's
legacy and it's used by the current
regime right well I I guess it to break
it down into two simple categories one
would be economic and the other would be
political and social certainly this
regime has inherited a communist
communist dictatorship which insists on
a monopoly of power and which deprives
everybody else in China of the right to
challenge that monopoly power and
deprives people of the freedom of
assembly and the right of access to
information including information about
their own history so it to that extent
arm it this this regime has in has truly
inherited some of my many of my
achievements and they are critical ones
to keeping itself in power as you
probably know I mean the the control of
you know information which is vital to
opening up a society I mean while the
area I think the area of personal
personal space and personal freedom is
still expanding in China political
control and repression are actually
tightening that may seem paradoxical but
I think that is the case and in
particular the Internet as you may know
they have Western companies have sold
them the state-of-the-art technology
which is allowing the Chinese regime to
control the internet far more
effectively than before and and anyway I
find that very tragic that that in that
technology is coming from the West
certainly it's true on the economic
front there there have been huge changes
since a huge changes and opening up and
I am sure they have brought they have
brought it's brought a certain type of
freedom a considerable freedom for a
very large number of Chinese but it
should also be noted that you know one
very important area is is the right of
workers to associate the right of people
to form trade
defend their rights in in that area I'm
I am sorry to say I think it you could
say that is perhaps one of the key
legacies of Mao in fact one I'm afraid
one hard-nosed American economists wrote
this and says Mao's real contribution to
the success of the Chinese economy is
that he broke the working class more
effectively than any other 20th century
leader but he but it but it's the
Communist Party that that has carried on
that tradition and so they're the the
legacy um the the economic legacy is not
it they haven't broken completely with
what ma did I mean they've kept what is
useful for them to stay in power and
discard it other things
young add something on that what I think
of course I mean China today is very
extremely different now from Mouse days
I mean the kind of the number that
people have a much much better life now
and also a degree of personal freedom
which we Mao's days couldn't dream of I
mean the thing is this I mean of course
we want China to be better I want the
Chinese to have a better life and and
also the world wanted a China that they
the world can feel comfortable with and
safe with and at the moment in China you
know the selection of the leadership is
completed a secret and the policy-making
process is completely secret so we have
to rely on our pure luck that this
enormous economic power and sort of
military power to some extent is is
going to be benign we that that is a
pure we have to rely on luck and I find
that very very worried to myself as okay
what we're going to do because we've got
too many too many folks is ask the
questions will accumulate them and at
five to five can we do that
so one I just think we won't have time
can we get them in classes okay quick
answers quick questions quick answers
okay we're all under time discipline hi
thank you very much for coming I'm
keeping a course called strategies of
tyrants in the government department and
your book figures prominently on the
syllabus so my question is was there any
did now manage to cultivate any popular
appeal or did he govern was his reign
simply based on force and brutality or
were the Chinese people under illusions
at various stages at any point about him
and also did you revise your opinion of
trunk I checked during the writing of
this book or did the Chinese people
never really have a choice between a
good ruler and a bad ruler was it always
just sort of lesser or greater evil
okay well Mao sorry the word again very
good concept well the thing is that were
ramaraju in my days through personality
couch personality cult really has
nothing to do with genuine affection it
was to do with basically two things one
is is the fear is a terror that I mean
if you opt out or if you don't want to
worship Mao what would happen to you
what would happen to you you know like
my father he was he well anyway he died
and and and then the other factor is the
deprivation of information we really had
no choice you know I was brought up with
the count of Mao I mean a song where
every child in China learned to sing
which when two fathers closed mother's
closed but neither is as close as
Chairman Mao and even I mean for me I
think I'm reasonably intelligent it took
me years and years to be able to even to
question Mao in my in my head to spell
out his name that was extraordinarily
difficult I think people who haven't
lived under brainwashing really would
find it very very hard to appreciate the
power of brainwashing and the worship of
Mao was based on brainwashing revision
Chiang kai-shek quickly visual Junction
yes very much
vot undershirt and he became a much more
interesting character I mean to myself
you know I was brought up with you know
thinking he was this huge villain and
and so on but as we discovered he was a
much more complex character I mean in
the book we showed that you know a
chiang kai-shek the law you know the
long march 59 35 34 and 35 and Chiang
kai-shek could have wiped out the
Communists he didn't he led the
Communist survive because he had a son
who has kept a hostage in Russia by
Stalin and that was his his only blood
son at the air and Chiang kai-shek was
desperate to get his son back so he
traded in the survival of the Red Army
with the return of his son and he that's
one question here and then we'll go back
there yeah yeah I'm just struck by a lot
of the intellectual dishonesty here even
in terms of how this has been moderated
a lot of yes it the question would be
quick when it comes the point here is is
that one one China scholar is said that
this is a disaster for the China field
that's filled with historical errors and
far-fetched theories another one said
it's a major disaster for contemporary
China filled this the book has been
characterized as being filled with
half-truths misinformation and
distortions of the fact the fact of
matter it's that the conditions of lies
for the Chinese people from 49 to 76
improved tremendously in all spheres so
how can you have this program and say
that you're here to speak about human
rights for the Chinese people or any
rights for the Chinese people when
you're not having that discussion I mean
there's no there's no there's no
discourse here want to answer that so
what you've not I think those were I
mean these general accusations are so
frustrating because what we want
are some facts I mean the facts for
example what would the improvement of
Chinese people's lives during Mao's
reign and the facts are the Chinese
people have a catastrophic life they
have such horrible life and the Chinese
regime itself acknowledge that you know
mouse rule was some kind of was the
unprecedent to the catastrophe the year
Mao died in 1976 the average food intake
in China was lower than in the 1930s and
that was the Chinese official statistics
well ok Jon you answered life expenses
yeah and and in the 1970s the average
income of the Chinese people was lower
than dirt poor Somalia I mean Mao really
I mean during the famine which was
created by Mao 38 million people died
and I don't know I mean these people
don't produce any facts but just some
assertions to defend this this
indispensable thing to join you happy
about it my life expectancy ok well I
mean there are two points so one is
about life expect its life expectancy
went up under the Communists by
considerable amount it's absolutely true
but there are you know there are reasons
for this first of all when when civil
war or civil strife ends life expectancy
goes up everywhere if I remember rightly
even in Zimbabwe under Mugabe life
expectancy rose by about 18 years very
rapidly once civil strife civil strife
ended and that and in the other thing is
at the other one other factor of course
is that in the 1950s I mean world
medicine made great advances I mean life
expectancy went up everywhere in the
world and we're talking of course about
a relatively low base I mean you know in
1949 is in some ways the most
advantageous year for the Chinese
Communists to choose to stop
from because it comes after a decade of
Japanese occupation etc etc so we could
get into all those statistics but if I
may say so there there is there there
seems to be I can't I can't answer it
because I haven't read this stuff that
gentleman is quoting but there is a
moral it is absolutely right that one
must record exactly what happened under
any political leader and for example it
it is if I mean if I may give this it's
this comparison of it to do with life
especially as well I mean we know that
Hitler and the Nazis for example were
very against tobacco and they even
linked tobacco to lung cancer
but the reason where they were
interested in this was because they
wanted to improve output they wanted a
fitter labor force
Mao took an interest in official a or in
a fatal labor force but one has to look
at the moral issues involved and one has
to also look at the larger moral picture
which is you know is it while recording
all the facts it is a it's a pretty
tough moral proposition to start saying
the guy who caused all these deaths and
wrecked our tens of millions of lives
and induced fear and terror for the
entire 27 years of his reign you know so
you you're being unfair I mean certainly
all the facts must be there but there is
there can't be any kind of moral quote
back to start balancing one of these
things against somebody who committed
all these horrendous things I think is
really out of course question here my
name is Ned tevin's I'm a graduate of
the Kennedy School my question has to do
with the American perception of the
rivalry between Chiang kai-shek and Mao
for the years before 1950 the American
perception was very heavily influenced
by Henry Luce and it was a man by name a
Theodore white a Harvard graduate spent
some time in China and
and his writings about China were
heavily edited by Henry Luce furthermore
the American State Department had
several capable young diplomats that I
knew who were in China during World War
two taking of Jon Stewart service and a
man the name of John Paton Davies their
view was quite different from the view
promoted by Henry Luce kucik with regard
to rivalry between Chiang kai-shek and
Mao could you comment on that place yes
okay well I mean actually we interviewed
both Jack's service and John Paton
Davies for the book and a number of
other people who've been with them are
Indian and on the so called Dixie
mission um I I mean in a nutshell I
would say the the the view amongst many
American diplomats and military men that
Chiang kai-shek was far from an ideal
ally it had a lot there was plenty to
that but the but the corollary of that
which was held also by people like
general Stilwell the corollary that that
somehow the Chinese Communists were
fighting the Japanese and were a useful
military ally to the United States I
think was profoundly wrong and for
example I went back recently and read
jack services summer Jack services
reports from yen an and they are
basically if I may say so they're
completely useless there are abuses in
terms of formulating policy for the US
government and I mean it I think the
other thing is about Chiang kai-shek
ease it's it is true the government was
extremely corrupt it's true it was very
unpopular but the most important thing
is that it was chiang kai-shek on the
nationalist who after all over eight
years put up the moat by far the most
important military resistance to the
japanese and played a you know a
substantial role in the pacific war the
Chinese Communist says as we as we
documented even from their own sources I
mean it did not fight the Japanese and
that was the core that was the core
issue for Roosevelt at anyway during the
Second World War
we've got time for two more questions
one here and one here
as you touched on the perception within
China remains much the perception of Mao
remains much different than the rest of
the world perceives it I'm really
curious if there's been any reaction
from China the Chinese government if
it's been published in Chinese I don't
imagine it's available in China but has
there been any reaction from ya about
your book well the I'm doing the Chinese
translation myselfi so there isn't the
Chinese translation yet it's going to be
published next year um a beginning of
next year but the Chinese government of
course bans they spoke strictly I mean
even magazines like the London Economist
had the pages of the book review
physically torn out out of the magazine
and when when when the Economist was on
sale and peaking on sale in Beijing
pages room yes oh sorry yes that the
pages the pages they actually sent
people to have physically tear out of
them the pages so their policy is to
block anything about our book from the
Chinese people I mean there was another
magazine the Far Eastern Economic Review
which that that particular issue which
carried a review of our book was banned
from entering China and they were given
the reason that this was because this
issue carried a review of our book so
that is their view um question yes
Kristof in New York Times yesterday in
his review of your book seems to agree
with you that mal was a monster and a
sense of human rights but he does say it
seems to me that there your book is
somewhat one-dimensional in that and he
I'm I'm gonna quote now Myles legacy is
not all bad land reform in China like
the land reform in Japan and Taiwan
helped to lay the groundwork for
prosperity today I might also add that
miles supported when there was a big
division within the party he supported
the those he opposed those who said they
wanted to maintain a dual enemy policy
and supported leaning toward the United
States which of course led to Nixon's
visit and the move away from the Soviet
Union
so my question really is are there not
positive features that of Mao's policies
even if his he was as as Christoph says
a human rights monster the land reform
of course is a very good idea as a land
reform
I wish China's land reform had been
carried out like in Taiwan or Japan but
mouths land reform was completely
different I mean to start with the land
that was given to the peasants were
taken back through two or three years
later I mean they were all taken back to
the state through the collectivization
so to start with this land reform of
giving land to individual peasants was a
complete Sharad now the Maui is the land
reform as the most important thing about
it is not about a division of land but
about violence
I mean people you ask anyone in China
who lives through that period they would
not remember e of the land reform was a
process called the dirty drew which is
struggling against the landlords which
is struggling against anywhere
relatively rich all victims designated
by the regime and typically these people
would be stood in front of the entire
village and they would be abused they
would be a spat on had mum you know
being tortured with gruesome ways and
men in beaten to death and that process
that scene ascent horror terror waves
into everybody's heart and this was what
Mao wanted he wanted to scare the
population from the word go so they
would be
obedient to the regime and would carry
out what the regime wanted and in fact
when Mao tried to impose his style of
land reform on Vietnam I mean that
Vietnamese revolted and the whole Ho Chi
Minh and other Vietnamese leaders
rejected it okay that's the land reform
and the other one is the Nixon's visit
right ma Y Mao invited Nixon and he
invited Nixon for two reasons one was to
put himself on the center of the world
stage and the other reason was by then
he had fallen out with with the Russians
fallen out because ma was trying to
rival the Russians for the leadership of
the Communist camp and world revolution
surgery so he fell out with Russians and
Mao had been dependent on the Russians
to get military military hardware
military industries and arm you know
nuclear weapons and so on because mouse
single-minded goal after he took power
was to build this superpower so he could
dominate the world but he'd fallen out
with the Russians in the 1960s and
China's nuclear industry was in shambles
Mao desperately needed a kiss of life
from foreign technological intake and he
tried to tune in you know to get to get
on with Nixon to try to get military
secrets out of America and Nixon's
visits is always said to have opened up
to you know open the door to China I
mean so far as some Western businessmen
some Western journalists visited China
and that's true but for the Chinese
people in China the door was not open it
was as closed as before
I'm the door really opened when after
Mao died so Nixon's visit did the mouth
dis certainly didn't invite nixon your
order to open the door
of China
just one example nixon visited shanghai
for one day for this one day the regime
rounded up tens of thousands of people
you know young people like myself in
those days young who had come back from
their places of Exile in the villages
back to Shanghai for the Chinese New
Year I mean the regime summary rounded
these people up and send them back to
their places of eggs exile in in case
somehow these people would appreciative
and say something against the regime
the chances of which were completely
remote and yet I mean he didn't want to
take that chance and by the way the many
for many peasants the years after
Nixon's visit 1973 to 1976 the year of
Mao's death they remembered those years
as the most hungry years and this was
because after Nixon visited China all
these countries recognized China and Mao
started to dole out foreign aid I mean
that the country is receiving aid from
China jumped from I think it was was
masseur teeing or something 266 so and
most of the aides were food and so the
Chinese peasants were were starving
actually after Nixon's visit and the I
mean they remember this period as after
the Great Famine I mean the years after
Nixon's visit for the most hungry years
so there you have it a portrait of Mao
by Jung Chang and John Holliday I want
to thank them for coming to the Carr
Center being right
I want
I want to I want to thank Mao the
unknown story is published by Knopf
visit aah